and so you'll have to get used to slower
zones and slower speed zones around
schools when classes start again on
monday police
will definitely be out in full force and
the east valley this morning
searching for bad drivers that's where
we find hector mejia live near eastern
owens with the details hey hector
hey there an enforcement here starts in
less than 30 minutes right at seven
o'clock we're at an intersection right
by owens and eastern we have three local
ccsd schools
right next to this crosswalk so earlier
we were trying to uh press the button
waiting for the traffic to come by to
see if any of the drivers would stop so
here we're going to press the crosswalk
button
lights turn on telling drivers to slow
down and stop and off to the left we
have one vehicle
stopping right now or actually going
since they're saying nobody's going to
use the crosswalk
but the main message this morning
actually right now we see police here
driving by
that is part of the enforcement that
kicks off at seven o'clock this morning
we're talking about north las vegas
police
metro police ccsd police driving home
the message
hey slow down look at the signs children
are walking to school
joining us live we have erin breen good
morning to you good morning hector
tell us about the activity going on
today huge and important for all the
parents
children and the bad drivers too and
especially the bad drivers yes so
today we're out doing pedestrian
enforcement and of course the idea is
for people to see it on the news
and be reminded that school starts on
monday
and we're going to be looking for cars
driving slower and not like that
gentleman
and stopping for children on their way
to school and so we're at a school
crossing zone
it's not a school zone but it's a
crossing zone so it's reduced speed
lights will be flashing and when you see
that to understand fines are higher
if you get a ticket in a school zone or
a school crossing zone
and the whole idea is to make children
safer on their way to school and
we need everybody to do their part take
their foot off the gas slow down
pay attention act like it's your
children that are walking to school
and this is just one example police will
be setting up not just at crosswalks but
also school zones
once school begins on monday absolutely
absolutely so
here's why so at 50 at 20 miles an hour
10 percent of the population struck by a
vehicle
will not survive and that 10 percent is
the very elderly
and small children because they have no
body mass to absorb the crash force
that's why we ask you to slow down
because if you
strike a child they won't live plain and
simple
erin thank you for your time we'll be
posting more information also an
update on just how many traffic how many
tickets they issue throughout the day
later on at noon for now reporting live
hector mejia
8 news now back to you